hi I'm Greg I'm John I'm nervous what is
this this is iterative peri-peri period
during the Korean PLN Jared Perry Nimr
al-nimr from the Collider video channel
and she is P Nemiroff on Twitter and
nanogram John already knows this about
me I'm half Italian half Filipino okay
this is important fact why because a few
weeks ago have you ever heard a
restaurant called jolly beat the
Filipino restaurant okay Filipino fast
food chain there're a couple of them
around here and they're released these
converting I call it jolly what Jollibee
Johnny D they really had commercials
from the Philippines that were very
emotional
oh no and I cried out on to them and I
like said stop and then I watched
another one that was called create
courage I watched with John which was a
Star Wars Pro as a know these are like
short films and that one was very
emotional to when you watch that with us
now she cried oh no way to cry early
phases okay challenge us challenge
that's a crock and then I watched
another one called a brief experiment
this is my way of getting in touch with
my Filipino community watching the
commercials the air over there is from
Angie love Angela when will love will
love so weird rule of your reaction
please react to coca-cola the last
customer I don't know if this is going
to be emotional Perry I have no idea Jon
I feel like you know when you're lying I
don't know Jon has a design up and I'm
fine I believe it starts off and ends
with that like a book in the past I came
out a while ago
[Music]
during this new series of randomly
focusing on a path of a truck
Villalobos avisail aluminum disk in the
cupola a Chicago accessibility
accessibility up not my garden table
absolutely I'm focusing lately weakness
in specular may not be paying in
organics we are brothers for the Wabash
Valley Latino food how can I please do
this madam cavalli-sforza my face - oh
my god ah just daughter suppose I let
you push the throttle for their
programming
[Music]
they were open and look after us all but
know what I got a call or a tiger need
up looking with a lemon investable nice
cheap pharmaceuticals ever allow unity
between for me from here we may get some
of the Logano marbles with it and use it
now that's a illa hey without it I'll
need it if people hanging around
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
hahahaha
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
whoa waiting couch coca-cola
[Music]
I know I'm curious now oh I'm very
touching very marketing like that that
makes me way cool my mom is the Filipino
one achieve loves coca-cola to fill Diet
Coke
this is been dyed coke commercial that
I'd show it to my mom the wait a minute
so the Philippines a place where just
like that's all you need to do to market
is just like show people the goodness of
humanity and then to maybe purchase of
coke that's the nicest kind of marketing
it's really I don't get my nearly enough
of it no no it's a vision are also
lengthy commercials like that's all how
they were like short films so today air
these like Evan you know like we air
commercials on TV they might air like
that special times or they air in
between like your friends reruns I guess
one of the difference Oleg how do we
produce is like it didn't matter that it
was four minutes 30 seconds it certainly
didn't feel like it
ambushed you read a little Sesame Street
I remember what it was like when you
have to I mean every oh well I
technically work you know I saw more
reaction on Christmas happening haha
let's swim away sacrifice let's
sacrifice a week a couple hours to put
it up on YouTube with all the tag all
those tags someone's guys has is so good
type of tagging to make sure to get seen
we're on the next year we typed all you
tags yeah thank you go get going this
video has a hundred percent water bills
before our YouTube you know was a way to
make a living there I would I would have
joy somewhere KB Toys did you really
know is that wouldn't actually I love K
bees or I still vividly remember the KB
toys that I used to go to the North Pole
cool mom I remember exactly I was like
well working at a KB Toys
sucks I got Christmas Thank You Tamara
well either shut down and ours is in
like Sherman Oaks I don't think it was
probably as impressed yeah no I worked
at Kristen's I worked the holidays there
and everyone is buying all these point I
love toys you've seen my collection of
Ren
toys in my living room yeah yeah well
you got a nice toy set up yeah well my
marbling and matter the best I know they
love work you do ya know those are the
kind of toys I like and every trip is
these little girls are just buying a
man's toy from me you know know
everybody like action figures are like
comic book characters Misha is my little
cousins get pop ya with toy and me I'm
like this is what it's meant to our
child buying a Funko pop and I'm just
like don't take it out of a lot I've
worked the holidays you know to make
sure I could have money it's like you
work up again yeah we all done the tree
like work and make money for the holiday
and then all your money goes oh I'm
gonna get hit that's cool I've been
fortunate I don't think I've ever had a
job where I had to work on Christmas Day
I have but I'm Jewish so doesn't matter
that's true I actually used to request
Christmas Day so I would get off
Thanksgiving oh and that would be even
trade for New Year's and Jewish people
celebrate what again
sure but I'm bummed
yeah that noise we need a sound boil in
this thing yeah we should buy coke thank
you Jeff you know behind this man
actually probably will buy coke man you
gotta watch out for my nose if the ones
I saw were Jollibee were like short
films yeah here I kind of wish that we
lived in a country where commercials
were short films and says yeah like
instead of car commercials that look
like they're for something else and so
you realize that her car annum what I
mean nothing
any time I watch one of these
commercials I'm gonna remember that
product it's good being out I think
that's the thing that stands out about
this for me is like they find a way to
weave the product back in and like
remind you in a way that's not totally
out of nowhere because all those ones
I've seen lately is it like message just
kind of end with why Chevy yeah like
this is weird get it oh really they
don't make sense yeah exactly
obviously you would put a coke on the
conveyor belt in the supermarket
you a drink oh yeah it's a great opening
gift to go you're like oh they just
think we're getting colon does an A+ job
of decorating their products exactly
ideally I feel a happy brothers look my
real tear so there are real people who
are being rewarded
that wasn't a guy the restaurant yeah I
mean for people who are that close to
their family can't be with her family on
the holidays like that's pretty awesome
the family and the girl that's a like
wrap gifts furtive works on Christmas
and then she gets out of school it's
kind of I thought a little bit annoying
if I was in her position I might be like
why do you make me wrap all these gifts
100 I have it it's like when the guy got
all the groceries and bagged them and
then they were like these are all for
you they like wrap all the groceries up
it was convenient for the cabinet out
there is a thrill to unwrapping a
present present
oh yeah like up until the point when
they had the big reveal this was just a
routine day for summation maybe she
didn't pay that much attention to what
she was wrapping it or maybe she was
what having going that stuff is so cool
I wish I could have this for Christmas
and then BAM
handsome Joe Filipino number four says
this is yours maybe she's just a super
fast rapper and it was like nothing you
actually like a rap god yeah
[Laughter]
not that I'm gonna go get climbing on
that one yeah well no God you can
subscribe you the real rejects the half
Filipino channel with all of our content
calm roll Islands made from the
Philippines and we'll be reviewing that
this week keep a look out for that
review Filipino Kong movie that we've
all wanti know receiving oh yeah is more
of this John this reason tsageri are
really good put her in your social media
manager of blunt house in the real
rejects that's right
be cool never wrong yeah do that every
number wrong on Collider videos in the
shamone what's your team called again we
are tough beat oh yeah where I am where
I leave that dog bit of a rat Queen T
number off on Twitter and Instagram so
go follow her there like her photo yeah
especially the ones that deputy
youie oh she just takes screenshots of
David Arquette oh yeah there's more
pictures of Minecraft I'm very proud of
that